je propose au public de rencontrer le
texte
je le mets en contact avec le texte
d'une façon tout à fait originale et
nouvelle pour qu'ils puissent ressentir
entendre et comprendre ce chef-d'oeuvre
d'aimé césaire qui est connu et en même
temps qui reste encore bien méconnu pour
de nombreux électeurs martiniquais
donc je créé ce concept je suis seul sur
scène à l'habitation la fontaine dans un
cadre de prestige dans un très beau
cadre
et puis je suis face à un micro et quand
j'ai créé ce concept je pensais aux
grandes chanteuses de jazz et blues et
aux grandes chanteuses de musique
orientale comme oum kalthoum et
chanteuse de jazz et de blues comme
billie holiday ella fitzgerald et j'ai
voulu donner à entendre ce texte d'une
manière tout à fait nouvelle et
différente que ce que j'ai l'habitude de
faire c'est-à-dire des créations
théâtrales gens tentent de la cale
monter les malédictions enchaîné les
rocket man des mourants le bruit d'un
qu'on jette à la mer les à bois d'une
femme en gésine comme tous les grands
textes ils ne se laissent pas comprendre
facilement
c'est à dire que les grands auteurs nous
demande à nous les lecteurs de faire un
effort de faire un effort intellectuel
de faire un effort émotionnelle pour
arriver à accéder à la compréhension de
ce texte dont cahier d'un retour au pays
natal a été pour moi d'abord un texte
difficile à lire
mais ça fait maintenant plus de 20 ans
que je le pratique je le travail que je
le manipule dans tous les sens et plus
je travaille plus je me rends compte que
c'est un très grand et très beau texte
et justement je suis tout à fait
conscient du niveau de difficulté de ce
texte
et c'est pourquoi en tant que comédienne
et en tant qu'enseignante mais vendredi
soir je serai plus
mediène je veux accompagner les lecteurs
et leur donner confiance leur donner des
clés pour qu'ils puissent lire ce texte
par eux mêmes